hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
listen you know what's crazy
right now i'm standing in a very
expensive area okay this is becky's
field
i live here and here's something really
crazy about this area
rooms to rent okay you want to rent a
room
in this area in beckham's field which is
in buckinghamshire just north of london
guess how much you're gonna pay to rent
a room you're gonna pay
about four to five hundred pounds per
month
to rent a room okay you want to live in
one of these rooms
do you want to live in a room in
beckensfield it's gonna cost you about
four to five hundred pounds a month
however
if you're gonna buy a house here you
wanna buy a little apartment
you're gonna buy a house it's gonna cost
millions
millions it's gonna pay millions to buy
but then you're gonna rent the rooms out
for four or five hundred pounds a month
if you don't believe me you go on spare
room code uk i'm saying the truth
brother right yeah
say the truth go on spare room don't
credit uk look in this area
let me just back this up right now let
me show you what i mean if we go through
the spare room.code at uk
sparringroom.com uk horse's mouth
type in beckons field flatmates
rooms wanted so this is how much people
are prepared to pay for a room
in beckham's field and you can see
there's many pages 500 600 pages and
pages
650 these are people's budgets these are
brand new people
350 125 500 400 450 350
okay so they're looking to pay about
what i mean some are 450 fine
but some 350 but on average you're
talking about
500 pounds to rent a room
moving asap okay cool but how much does
it cost
to buy a house in beckons field
well i'm telling you now on average
you're probably talking
at least a couple mil so let's see so in
beckons field
we'll look for um three a three
three bed houses and let's see what we
got
i mean these are like six six male let's
just look from newest listed okay
there's quite a lot of houses
it's just average houses okay these are
like 850 this is just added but this is
this is for a um
this is guide price this is on an
auction there you go
2.6 million okay 600
grand guard prices again they'll
probably sell for a lot more than that
so in this area you can see again guy
price 1.75 million
um 1.4 million i guess it depends on the
part of beckons field
but on average you probably took a
million pound then for a house
okay including the little small ones
look 5.5 million
okay 2 million okay cool but but here's
the thing
here's the thing if we go back to spare
room
for the so to buy a house you're talking
at least 750 grand
but average maybe a million two million
and the rooms are renting for like
four or 500 pounds a month but if we go
to warsaw
now warsaw is where i grew up that's my
hometown oh my goodness look at that the
rooms
are renting for the same four fifty
seven fifty six hundred
the rooms are in for the same four fifty
they're ready for the same
so you're gonna pay the same amount for
a room
okay maybe tiny bit less okay maybe a
tiny bit less but
500 pounds room new so maybe you go up a
tiny bit less but they're pretty much
the same price
but if we go back to right move
and if we search houses for sale in
warsaw
and you know i know that the the really
fancy houses in beckensfield are
millions but there's quite a lot of very
average looking houses
but they're selling for like a million
so let's let's
let's see what the craic is in warsaw
let's see what's just come on this new
morsel
so we'll do uh newest same same story
new is listed and
400 results 160
added yesterday okay one nine six one
six five two fifty
like 150 there's loads for sale
look 60 grand see guy price i told you
it's always cheap because they want more
but but 200 250
there's a lot of 140s nice house so for
the same housing if that was in
beckensfield it'll be
750. so it's it's it's not double it's
not triple it's like quadruple the price
but the rents are the same
you're gonna pay four to five hundred
pounds a month to rent a room why is
that crazy
that's crazy because the rooms
cost the same to rent pretty much
wherever you are in the country
even in the world you go to uh you go
you go to um
america all right lots of bots you're
gonna pay about the same to rent a room
you're gonna pay four to five hundred
pounds a month you're gonna pay four to
five hundred pounds a month in edinburgh
you're gonna pay four to five hundred
pounds a month in swansea in stoke on
trent
you're gonna pay about four to five
hundred pounds a month for a room even
though in stoke-on-trent you can buy a
house for a hundred thousand pounds you
buy the same house in beckham's field
and you're gonna you're gonna spend a
couple million
pounds so why is that that's because
people that rent rooms just want rooms
they're moving maybe for their job
they're moving from um
their their hometown their home country
to moving for a job
maybe the job could be aberystwyth or
maybe it could be bristol they don't
know
it's just the jobs the jobs the job the
rooms the room the room so what's the
trick if you're an investor well the
trick is
don't there's there's no correlation i
hope you catch this
there's no correlation between the house
price
and the rent so you want to buy low
rent high that's my buck my book is
called buy low went high
buy low rent high with a property
manager nearby
okay so it's all about the roi you want
to put in as little as you can get get
back the most this is just crazy it
freaks me out
people buy houses in london and rent
them out for the same prices you could
rent a house out for in birmingham
sometimes at times
so london is a little bit of an
exception london
london center of course rooms aren't
going to be four to five hundred pounds
a month
but premium and people are going to try
and find you know find that area where
it's different but look general rule of
thumb
okay room prices are four to five
hundred pounds a month you can
look in liverpool newcastle
birmingham beckons field it's just
outside of london which is really
expensive to buy a house
rooms are the same house prices
fluctuate massively
so you want to be getting a good roi buy
low rent high
anyway i had to get it off my chest
smash the like button subscribe i'll see
you tomorrow